welcome to another episode of the
recruitment mentors podcast this is the
show where i deconstruct how some of the
most successful recruiters and
recruitment entrepreneurs have remained
at the top of their game by uncovering
their mindset their approach to
leadership and much much more in this
episode i was joined by patrick waites
who is one of the co-founders of coltec
he's been in recruitment for coming up
to 11 years we spoke about how he didn't
do a deal for eight months how he's
boxed with tyson fury and how over the
last three years he's grown his company
to 15 16 people strong they're doing 7.5
million in revenue and they have huge
plans to take over in the us and
specifically austin i hope you enjoy the
episode so
pat welcome to the podcast thanks for
having me it's um just to set the scene
we're in a place called dream factory
it's um
a really cool place it is really nice i
was actually surprised downstairs i'm
glad hopefully this can become part of
the experience but i haven't done a
face-to-face podcast for a while so it
might be a bit rusty that is my first
time as well
let's have some fun mate so i guess
where i always like to start on this
podcast is
just to ask a million pound question and
i'm sure a question that you thought a
lot about when hiring for your own
recruitment business but i guess i'd
love to find out from you what what you
sort of deem the characteristics and
traits that make up like a highly
successful recruitment consultant in
today's market
it's a really interesting question
because there's so many
facets or different things that
work so dif different people have
different like uh ways of working that
were better for them than than someone
else uh however like the
bl indoor which is you've got to be like
driven
a driven person who's got like just a
target that they want to hit with
financially
uh within their own uh life career like
progression have someone who's always
looking forward yeah and so you've
always got yeah you've got to be driven
and have uh have something that you're
aiming for and then in today's market i
think the the ways of working are
changing slightly
uh from maybe a more traditional or um
old-school approach of you know you know
phone always works obviously in phone
bashing and fails but it's much more
about being able to build a solution for
a client than offering transactional
recruitment sure um i think that the
days of
uh you know bums on seats or giving
people a cv and you know sending tvs to
clients i'm hoping for the best they're
dying out now anyway i believe and i
think within the next three or four
years um you'll see a complete change in
all businesses and we've gone on that
journey ourselves and would be much more
of a
staffing solutions partner rather than
uh you know a transaction yeah
transactional consultant so i think yeah
in the modern market having the ability
to be able to work with a client and
talk to them about
solutions rather than people yeah for
sure that's really important and just to
build an endeavor you've got to be
driven
did you did you always have that drive
do you think yourself
yeah i think uh like historically
i've always wanted to do better at what
i'm doing or you know i always wanted to
always looking forward basically so
whether it be that with the boxing when
i was younger um
having the target i want to get on
england squad the weather yeah i want a
box of england i want to win this title
and that was very much obviously an
individual obviously a part of a club or
a team but it's an individual driver
you've got to to do that yourself um
in recruitment i've always uh yeah
always had ambition to do more than what
i have been so yeah itself i'm quite a
driven person yeah where do you think
that came from that because i'm sure
that that's what you're looking for in
other people yeah but do you think was
it did your parents play a plot in that
was growing up or yeah so my my mum
massively um
my dad as well obviously but um my mom's
always worked really really hard um i
think she had me when she was like 18.
she was a young mum yeah
and
she's ended up doing pretty well from
you know
child blocking nor footage to like
being where we are now is you know
she's she's had that drive herself so
i've seen that um and they're just
everyone in my family my uncles my aunts
love always
my cousins have all um you know they've
all done pretty well um in their chosen
areas um and it's just shown that hard
work yeah gets you somewhere because uh
yeah didn't obviously have like the
greatest starts or like there weren't a
leg up yeah yeah so having that
uh around you mm-hmm and just the people
you surround yourself with as well i
suppose all of my mates have done pretty
well for themselves because it said that
you become like the people that you hang
around with
like you have the ambition that they
have or if you see people doing well you
want to do it so um i think
you've got you it's like it's in you
anyway a little bit but you can get
brought out by surrounding yourself with
other people i think yeah yeah i'm just
curious because i think i'm sure
sometimes you've had those people that
you've led or managed where you just
want to like shake them and like give
them that drive
you know just curious like where you're
where you just think like yeah i'm just
curious where you where you think that
can come from and it seems like you said
you've spoken around your friends family
growing up but yeah because i'm sure you
have people and i have had people in
your teams where
you're just like i just wish they had a
bit more drive every everyone does like
it's like everyone's had it you can get
it in all walks of life not just in work
right yeah look at people and be like
what are you doing yeah you don't see
the opportunity you've got here or yeah
yeah you can do that so
some people like as i say it's just it's
it's in you but it can be brought out by
the environment that you put yourself in
that's what you're trying to build a
cold check is that environment where
everyone wants to push forward yeah so
so loads of things that we can go into
here so i think where where i really
want to focus is cold tech on that
journey but before we do
i'd i'd love to just i guess just hear a
bit there's always typically a story as
to how someone got into recruiting as
you mentioned you
um was really into your boxing yeah
before so i guess tell us a bit about
one how you got into recruitment and
then two how you feel like the boxing
side of things maybe gave you that
competitive edge or um gave you those
traits or things that you've been
working on in a sports environment and
then in a commercial professional
environment um so how i got into
recruitment uh
i was sort of floating around jobs
really really i didn't really have
anything particularly i was doing and
then i bumped into my mate might and
badou shout out easy
and he said oh yeah i've got started
working this company synergy
and they're looking for people like do
you want to uh join a job i was like
yeah i need one so yeah why not so yeah
i went and went for the interview
bumbled my way through yeah got in and
then yeah just
it was more of like just i needed a job
really really yeah they weren't like oh
yeah i love record i love the idea of
recruitment it was just like he said
that's what i could do like talking to
people
um quite a social job
sales you know that's the sort of area i
wanted to get into
and it just happened yeah my mate was
working at the company's looking for
people and that's how i got got into it
and then
yeah that was
11 years ago now yeah with this yeah
it's my 11th viewing recruitment so yeah
then this system that's one of the
greatest things about recruitment right
yeah it's just a low barrier of interest
you know what i mean yeah if you want a
job
there's pros and cons there's pros and
cons to that but i think
like yeah what you've then been able to
to build for yourself yeah it's so with
that it is very much like if you want it
you can go and get it
more so than a lot of other um
industries or careers or jobs like if
you actually want
something can you set a target like i
said if you've got that drive
and you're you're in environment that
brings it out of you or um gives you a
pathway to get to where you want to get
then you know the sky's the limit yeah
he's done all right like i've done
reasonably i'm happy with my career so
far and i'm really excited about where
it's going with regards to like the
boxing
i suppose what that
has been really good for me or and
anyone who's done sports or done some
sort of um
not even sport but something
where they've had to dedicate themselves
to to get to to earn something or to uh
achieve yeah
it proves that you can do something if
you put your mind to it so you get that
self-belief so when i started eating
synergy uh i didn't do a deal for the
first 13 months really yeah i don't know
how i've got 13 months yeah i don't know
how i kept my job
i think they just didn't want to lose
people and i was quite fun to have
random 19 months yeah i was really [ __ ]
oh wow um but i was doing all the like
so i don't know it was yeah i just
couldn't get my head around it i was
running like on the phone a lot yeah i
think i must still hold the record no
sorry that's a lot but it worked 30
months it took me 30 months to get from
trainee to consultant right that's
that's definitely still a record it was
eight months got it you got it and you
get your first laptop my first deal
was eight months right and that was uh
it turns out ironically i've done a
resource deal for my now for matt who's
my business partner right and it was for
a tester who uh who then left two weeks
in
yeah um yeah we always talk about that
so just just quickly i know because
that's quite a common thing isn't it
like a proper
classic thing that people would look for
as yeah they come from a sports
background and these things then you
said i think it's that self-confidence
that they put their mind something they
haven't given up competitive environment
all these things
i have i have to um i have to ask you
like i watched that video of you
spurring uh tyson fury he just looked
humongous compared to you so i'm not
like a small bloke i want my sick one
i look like a child next to him yeah i
guess all i was just curious i was just
curious because i'd like i um i love his
journey and i'm big into boxing myself
and all of that i guess from what you
sort of your experiences with him are
you surprised what he's gone on to do
because that was not seven eight years
ago you know so yeah it's just good to
hear that from you yeah so that was uh
funny how that happened we just yeah i
got invited one of my mates mates with
him okay and then he invited us to go
into the gym and then we was just there
training whilst he was there and he went
really spy he was just sort of just
hungry
but no like in terms of what he's gone
on to do
so as to answer that question did i
always think that he'd be like a
champion of yeah 100 right there's no
doubt in my mind that i've said that
from
forever i think anyone in boxing who's
ever seen him said that he's got that
that the attributes to be able to go on
and do that that was actually the spa
just figured it was six months before he
fought klitschko and won the title
really yeah oh wow yeah so um yeah i'll
take a little bit of credit for that
and
that's it
like in terms of that his skills
attributes everything about him you
always knew that he'd go on and do that
yeah in terms of
what he's gone on to do from winning
falling down yeah all the addiction
issues uh like mental health issues and
so and then risen to where he is now and
being like
a it's someone that everyone can sort of
look up to yeah yeah um no i don't
what he's done is just incredible and it
does show that
don't say if you do have
a drive or an ambition or something and
no matter what position you're in yeah
yeah you can achieve it um and he's just
yeah to me he's just amazing like what
he's got what he's gone on to do it's
just um yeah it's been it's it's a great
like like you said fall down and rise up
story and that's it everyone can
point to that and go he was in the
position i was yeah and look at him now
sort of thing yeah he's top of the world
he's like um yeah just the hat's off to
him right he's just felt like a great
man like what he's done sounds fantastic
so i have to i have to ask you then
because this has come a few times right
why why didn't you quit then if it took
you that long to do your first deal
because i needed a job
[Applause]
why didn't you quit [ __ ] surely no
one's going to hire me
i think that was the only people that
would have me so
what can you get your head around what
can you like because people could relate
to this no it was it was like come in
right um and this is just saying like 10
11 years ago yeah um come in might get x
amount of manageable names today yes
amount of time on the phone get these
leads so i was like doing that
but i didn't know what i had to do with
that right information yeah yeah i'm
getting all these managers what i didn't
know you had to then ring them up and
pitch them
well i did know that but it just i don't
know for some reason it didn't click
yeah and then
as i've done that deal then
for that in two weeks so yeah um and
then uh
then it took me a little while i started
working again with a guy called gus who
really helped me yeah um young's company
called technology has done amazingly
well but he really helped me like just
resourcing with him and that stuff done
a couple of deals and then it
went until the owner of uh eastern
energy siri
um took me under his wing and really
sort of helped me
um spent some time with me
mentored me that showed me like helped
me out got me into a couple accounts and
showed me how to how to build them
and that i then
went from not doing any deals to to
building really really well and then
becoming the top miller within like 18
months of that so
so people listening then that might be
going through that
right now in terms of they're doing the
right things they're putting in volume
of activity they've got the work ethic
like what would you do there's got to be
a breakdown somewhere
so if you're doing all these things like
the volume of work right you've added
managers
there's got to be
something that for whatever reason isn't
clicking you've got to try and
have and as i say i was lucky enough
that i had siri take me under his under
his wing and helped bring out the what
the
you have to be working with someone who
can help you do that um that's really
really important for me in our business
is to help everyone sort of develop did
you proactively ask for help or
because i think that sometimes people
miss that like yeah
it went like a little bit but i think he
just saw it like just sort of come in
and uh
yeah just to help me like i i i do
everything to him really
from what we've what we've gone on to do
because a lot of the stuff that he
taught me is now how i still work now
and uh how we're how we're bringing
people through but yeah you won't know
you need to ask for help yeah i don't
know if i miss it i can't really
remember if unnecessary as i helped me
but like
there was like obviously a conversation
like
what are you doing differently to me
what am i missing yeah and then um yeah
all of a sudden just went bang and then
we went from you know
zero billions to like 18 grand a week gp
and you know
so i guess what people would want to
know just on this and then
we'll we'll go into cold tech
like what would you say
day to day you're doing
um like really differently compared to
when you obviously got to the use at the
top of the
leaderboard just working smarter
just yeah like i don't know
i can't even really say it just one day
all of a sudden just changed
i think
getting into a pretty decent account
helped
having more of a focus
looking at something so what we did we
did there was at the time the government
was going through like loads of digital
transformation yeah um and we found
an area that would we could sort of hone
in on okay and a way of working that
maybe some of us didn't so we started
working with systems integrators and
larger consultancies to
build teams for them on their government
projects okay um and then we sort of got
into one then we got into another one
into another another then was working
directly with the government as well so
that we could use that as a
as a case study so i think what the only
thing that really happened differently
is i managed to manage to get into an
account
and then use that experience to go
around and pitch other people
and sell that same solution and again
this was that solution selling
back like eight years ago seven years
ago like when it weren't really as much
of a thing it was more transactional
um and we was going in and pitching
building teams like you know digital
transformation helping
helping um deliver outcomes rather than
deliver uh people
yeah then that's once we sort of changed
once it sort of changed tack into that
not just me everyone around yeah
everyone in these synergies just went
boom boom boom
gp become like that's the standard that
you gotta meet um
and then again that was then you're in
an environment
where everyone's doing
these numbers
so you you feel
[ __ ] if you're not not that you are but
like you you feel like well i've got to
get there yeah that drives you one and
then everyone's like if you're in a
highly successful environment then
everyone drives each other on and that's
probably what changed from having like
one or two people leading the way to
then having that five six seven eight
people all putting in like these numbers
every month and then obviously he's
having a good time with it as well so
what so what what do you think sort of
recruitment's giving you that maybe you
least expected them like you fell into
it you needed a job like what what has
the career and what so far has it given
me that you least expected do you think
it's
it's definitely obviously like
like financial awards have been good
obviously but that's obviously what you
expect because we put in i think in
terms of
just growing up as a person really i'm
obviously it's i've been in it for about
10 years now to say so the 23 year old
guy that started
yeah i was 23
i always forget hold on i keep thinking
i'll keep thinking i'm 30 but i'm not
i said that anyway listen
who you are is completely different the
person i am is completely different yeah
but um just to have him now obviously
when we
own a company
it's more it's turned me into a business
person rather than a sales person that
makes sense so and that's something i
probably didn't expect i never expected
to be where i am now anyway um but yeah
it's definitely i've definitely changed
completely as a person as you would do
over growing up as a yeah in 10 years
but definitely a much better person than
when i started so so i guess final thing
on like the early days then like what
what what advice would you give to pat
starting out in recruitment would you
say like looking back now with hindsight
with everything that you know now what
would you maybe go back and say to pat
do you think has he kicked off his
career you know what
try and do a deal um
yeah quickly
pull your finger out in that one
um but i don't know if i'd change much
okay um like genuinely
obviously going through that hard spell
at the beginning
help me know that it's not always going
to be good yeah yeah so when times get
[ __ ] i know that i've been there before
you've been there so i know i can handle
that yeah so that was good grounding
really um
yeah i suppose i wouldn't really change
it
probably yeah just say like mate when
you're getting all this information try
and pitch it
um do that but yeah i think um
that's pretty much it like look just
keep working stay focused keep working
hard
i've obviously done some really stupid
stuff and i'd probably say try not to do
that um but overall all of that has got
me to where i am now i wouldn't change
too much to be fair so
let's talk about cold tech so obviously
it's i'm from what i saw you've been
going for three years now right yes
third birthday on the 4th of feb well
it's mega yeah three years yeah it's
exciting so i guess
like the first we're always like to
start is just like when most people
start
their own recruitment business they will
typically lead with we want to do it
differently like i'm going to take
everything i've learned and this is i'm
only going to do the things that i
really like blah blah blah i guess what
was
your and your business partner's
approach or mindset towards how you're
going to do things differently do you
think as you know it's super competitive
loads of recruitment companies out there
what was your initial mindset towards
doing things differently do you think
i think like what i touched on earlier
like the transactional model
is something that we
wasn't really focused on from day one it
was all around
pieces of work bundles
uh projects
delivering teams to our clients so it
wasn't we we wouldn't ever really go
after ones and twos it was more about
becoming proper partners with our
clients and and helping them on a
journey and as i touched on with the
synergy delivering an outcome yeah um
we was a lot more focused on that
uh because obviously after this energy
we're doing all that and then went to
rock which is a lot more transactional
stuff so i wanted to move away from that
um
and that's when we set the business up
that was the idea yeah um changed the
way in which we engage with clients and
how our clients engage with agencies so
it's a lot i'm going to impact this then
but really really quickly just just for
a reference for everyone so like where
as a business where you are today like
how many people do you have in the the
company currently
15 15. yeah well
no so it's like so well it'd be 16 as of
monday 16 of monday yeah okay cool and
then
third year what did you end up doing
revenue wise do you know
yeah um
it was like 7.5 million okay last year
but that gives people an idea right in
and around so let's work back from this
so
i'm really keen so one of the things i
did before christmas was just shared
sort of some key insights that i've
taken from last year's conversations and
one of them was
this solutions piece and i think
like the modern day recruiter the the
recruiters that
are going to future-proof themselves are
going to be people that are thinking
about solving real problems for their
for their clients right so let's unpack
this what how would you
how would you just really clearly
articulate the difference between a
recruiter that does one two three deals
with a client every quarter every other
quarter to what you're talking about
solutions outcomes what would you say is
the the main difference do you think in
terms of how to go about it or in terms
of we're going to go about it but how
would you just first like just say this
is the main difference compared to the
main difference is that yeah you're
actually a partner like you're working
with a client you know where they're
going as a business you're integrated
into their into what they want yeah
looking at their goals and objectives so
right you've got so you've got a project
coming up and you're building i don't
know you're building a new application
for your business where someone can sign
in and apply for a job on your um on
your website so you need to build a
whole new uh system for that so having
those conversations rather than all
right mate so you want a front-end
developer okay okay so what is this
actually going to do what is the impact
on the business if it doesn't happen um
and how we can how can we help you get
there and then it so it might be
that right
you want to build a
a permanent function in your business
but you know the market at the moment is
as it is and it's really really
difficult that's going to impact your
delivery of this piece of work which if
you're a startup or a scale-up business
you've got investors they're not going
to give you the money
to do the next part so that's going to
that's gonna impact you there so let's
put in a contract team
and then let them then he's going to go
take them in-house once like as and when
you want sure so then you should send in
something completely different
then going okay you're gonna need five
front end developers let me go see if i
can go and get them for you so what
what's the first step then that's what i
mean so people listen to this they might
go you know what i want to get to where
pat where pat is i want to be someone
that's deemed selling solutions i want
to be having those conversations but if
right now i'm a transactional recruiter
but i want to get there what's the first
step like how how can people go about
having those conversations with them yes
you've got your clients with customers
yeah you just got like the first step is
to just go and have that conversation
okay so speak to them what is going on
with your business obviously you've got
to find out where these projects are
going what's happening there nothing's
changed about that you've got to go out
and get the information however you go
however you get it but then go and speak
to people i've i've seen that you've
recently received funding and you're
going to be building this team about
what the hell can let me talk to you
about how we can help you do that it's
literally about get understanding
that you're not just there to give them
a person yeah it's there to solve the
problem that they've got and having that
conversation with clients so it's all
just about you say how did you go about
it it's about just going to do it yeah
and just being willing to have those
conversations yeah just changing the
text slightly um that's it so what so
right now then as cold tech do you have
like a suite of products then yeah so
we've got um
some different solutions that we offer
like three different ways of doing
contract teams uh and a couple of
different is it all contract that you do
or
so historically yes we've done a lot
more starting to do a lot more perm but
um yeah we're we're a contract driven
business um and then there's perm
solutions in terms of a lot of people
doing the same types of things like the
bundles yeah in-house outsourcing
what are these solutions called then
that'd be good for because people can
get sort of ideas from this or like what
are the three different solutions called
uh
for contract we've got uh like rapid
response teams where that is delivering
teams and then them going perm later on
yeah getting the team in quickly rapid
response teams yeah um
remote project teams uh and then you
just do your project delivery like
statement of the work stuff yeah yeah
and then for perm you've got like 10 as
a service uh bundles and uh
bundles so like you need five people and
then we'll just offer a different way of
right yeah so you're not going to pay
per person that's yeah yeah is paying as
a group so most of the the differences
are really around the commercials and
how you how they the people get
delivered in the time spans and how we
go about doing it yeah yeah and then
with that obviously you get
um clients get different ad on that we
use our tech stack so the video
interviewing platforms
uh we've got vincerie yeah uh uh shadow
and jerry
and yeah using those uh like the live
list and everything on that so
yeah it's
we've built a tech a way of working or
systems that we use
that enhance our ability to find people
enhance the customer experience for our
with our clients so it makes it easier
for them to make decisions um
and then obviously with that we wrap
around with the products that you know
we're actually delivering outcomes to
what we do so a lot of stuff that we do
is actually like fixed price we will do
this or like sort of like a consultancy
if we don't deliver we don't if don't
get signed off then we don't get paid
yeah hey everyone a real quick one from
me this podcast would not be possible
without our amazing podcast partners
vincerie and sauce breaker because you
listened to this podcast you were able
to get your hands on exclusive savings
on both of these award-winning products
if you're all a growing recruitment
business you have to check out vincerie
who are an all-in-one operating system
for your growing recruitment business
with sourcebreaker if you want to make
sure that all of your recruiters have
the best tools on the market to stand
out and beat their competition then you
have to check out sourcebreaker use the
link in the show notes in the comments
below and you'll be able to get yourself
exclusive savings on these amazing
products so all sounds great but there
must have been some challenges and some
bumps getting away mate no yeah it's not
the same
what's been some of the biggest
challenges and then would i talk about
america what's what's the delivering
that actual as a consultancy yeah and
building that piece out wasn't uh just a
lot of
just like a lot of failures along the
way a lot of not doing that yeah right
well so
so we've been running three years right
yeah in that time
uh brexit yeah i have 35 yeah was on
then off then on um covered
yeah well that's the you know that's
that two general elections covid uh
there's a plague of lotus i think at
some point coming in so i mean is that
literally like what more could happen to
us yeah um and as a small business or a
start-up business having all these
different things effect
um affect you like i said i think if i
lost a load of contractors there like
lots like two big projects gone um
kovid lost loads of work because that um
we had uh you know had a couple of
different ideas like talent as a service
things with businesses you know we're
not hiring anymore done shut down yeah
um
so we've scaled up gone back down um
so that's been hard um what was your
lowest moment you thinks yeah getting a
phone call one after like one
well we had like 20 people working out a
client yeah they're all gone
uh and then the next literally put the
phone down the next phone call was
another project where we had like six or
seven but was due to get a lot more more
yeah oh yeah that projects can that boom
so yeah within that two phone calls
losing like
pretty much your whole contract book
that was a really hard day
um
how do you manage that how do you like
because you must be thinking what the
[ __ ] am i gonna what are we gonna do now
i don't you've got peril
yeah so
it's really strange with that
i've never
ever worried about that really never
that i've always got
confidence
in myself and especially matt that he's
just an absolute beast like i don't know
it's
the best recruit i've ever seen um
so i've always got confident that we
could do it there's never ever been one
day where i thought i don't know if this
is gonna happen this is gonna work
if it's not you matt anymore there's
other human beings that you're
responsible at the time it was just me
and him
now obviously yeah like
again but i don't have i don't worry
ever really because i've got super
confidence in all my team that i just
did
yeah like as i said i didn't do a deal
for 13 months like for eight months
before so um i've seen hard times i've
lost my contract book
four or five times during my career that
i've that it's gone from being a lot
down to bottom so i've seen it all
happen but it's not always been great
for me that so i think those hard times
have kept me like
you can never ever get
too like hyped on your own [ __ ] when
you're doing well
or two down staying grounded you've got
to just try and stay like wow let's just
keep going because there's always naught
that you're always trying to get get
somewhere
so before before we talk about america
like in your in your view what
contract recruiters listen to this like
what what do they need to master what do
they need to get really good at that you
think so the official client solution
it's just like they have to learn how to
offer a client an actual solution that
is gonna um why is that so crucial then
because because that's the value add
that we have yeah that and if you don't
position yourself that way yeah
the transactional side of equipment in
my mind in my opinion is dying yeah and
that it goes through cycles so
those people that are just going to be
ring ups that will always work you
always make something yeah yeah but if
you want to develop and grow and do
really well you've got to learn how to
actually offer a client a solution to
their issues whether where's the problem
how what outcome you're getting to call
let's build a team to help you do that
yeah it's all about that that's that's
my opinion anyway um what do you think
the skills that surround that though
that maybe people need to work on or are
going to have to improve to it's all
about having
business conversations yeah with the
right people targeting the right type of
people uh like and having business
conversations not people conversations
that make sense yeah no i'll get him in
yeah so that that's where i i think more
consultative approach
um
the you know bring it up speculating tvs
and fields will always work to an extent
yeah um but you wanna
for me it's much more important or much
better way of working to have
five clients where you've got building
teams for them and projects then having
a hundred clients you've got one person
because you just it just makes more
business sense for you like it makes
more sense
when did america come on
the agenda there's another uh
when did that start that journey yeah
there's another up and down uh let's
talk about it so when did it when did
you start thinking
about two months into setting up really
we was like we started doing all right
in england and matt was doing really
well and i was like well look we want to
eventually go to america so let's just
do it now okay and um
matt listen like just say if you want to
do it do it sorry all right i'm gonna
we'll do it uh so i started working the
hours
on my own
um but it was cool with the hours what
would you do i'd do like 12 2 or 10 at
first yeah um
and then my partner got my missus got
pregnant yeah so it wasn't really like
well that wasn't working it wouldn't
really work that she was heavily
pregnant and me working all night and so
on and so forth so yeah of course and
with i
would move back to my mum's when we
started the business because obviously
we needed money so ready my house out
moved back to my parents so it's just a
lot um yeah so then that we put it
parked here yeah carried on building the
uk stuff and then it about i think
august last year was like right cool
let's let's do this properly give real
quick let's give it a go we'd set up an
infrastructure now because obviously we
tried i tried to rumble [ __ ] walk really
with the american stuff originally but
then as the business grew and we started
hiring people we had people in positions
it made more sense to them be able to do
it so we started that in august this
year it's decided on austin as the
location why did you decide on that
it's just a tech hub for like for the us
so many startups a lot of good
technology businesses
um it just has become like one of the
go-to places in america for technology
so
we uh we started on that decided on
there so then what was the strategy what
was like how were you going to crack
into this market you know what
we went a different way about it i was
obviously a big fan of your podcast
and i just thought you know what let's
do
much more community-led approach so so
what was the first step with that
because i went round
i went on meetup.com okay found that we
wanted to focus on a specific area
specific type of technology technology
specific type of business so fintech and
shaw tech okay um
and on meta.com and
found all different meetup groups or
event groups that was uh in the area
contacted the organizers
spoke to them about you know um where
come to us and we'd love to sponsor our
colleagues help you run some events was
that the outreach was it hey this is
what we do we'd love to help or support
in some way yeah yeah yeah so look we're
we've come to austin um and we focus on
in this sector yeah yeah and um yeah
really really keen to be part and embed
ourselves within the within the
community and um how's that received
really well really really well yeah so
then managed to start co-organizing and
sponsoring a few events
which then uh led to speaking online
within the forum on the meetup.com and
people saying i would like to have this
person or this person do a talk or
helping organize round tables i went out
to austin and done a panel
um meet up there uh then that developed
into i would like to hear from this
person so i didn't contact them so
people my group would like to hear from
you so we started the podcast yeah
justin tech leaders um and then from
there started building up a name
within the area and then work people
just sort of just gravitated towards us
and we're happy to work that's because
it's in the what we're doing there so
what's the key like how did you do that
in like an authentic way because i think
people obviously
people can be very aware of like
just your recruitment breath can't
they're like is he just doing this just
so yeah you can try to get on to the hot
like how did you make sure like because
it was authentic simply that it did it
come across often because it was i did
genuinely won't ask him for anything
yeah but i won't say oh if we do this do
you want to can you give us some work
yeah oh by the way i've got this cv here
no it was we're doing it because you
actually genuinely want to be a part of
this and get obviously that the
conversation was like look he's going to
get our name out there that's just you
know objective we know we want to get
our name out there but we also want to
be part of that yeah learn more about
the area find out more about the people
what makes the companies tick what
what's actually going on yeah um again
have those business conversations yeah
and then that would it was authentic it
wasn't uh
of
disguised yeah yeah do that so how what
about the commercials then how did that
end up playing out did people because
you weren't expecting anything people
actually said you know what pat what do
you guys do can you help is that is that
how it is
talking and then obviously through
conversation yeah oh we'll you know
we're growing and we're doing this
more about that you know i can help you
with that right yeah can you oh
brilliant well let's have that comment
and then yeah that's it and then do a
good job and now we're working
exclusively with
as partners and doing all these deals
with quite a few businesses out there
now so it's worked really really well
and the team go out and do that now
right so everyone that's working
with us in america has now got their own
sort of um meet up or community group
that they run in yeah so um
that's that's how we're going about it
so what would you say people listen to
this and they want to that would love
the opportunity to start something like
that what would your advice be to them
do you think
if they were like you know what find
something you actually care about okay
so i actually am interested in that
sector yeah yeah and it's really like
yeah i'm
quite into it so
find something you're interested in and
actually
don't do it if you're actually just
doing it to get money at the end right
it's not that's not the
it it's weird that is the goal yeah if
that's the only reason if that's you're
only doing it because you're gonna try
and then don't like don't bother just go
back try something else because it's
gonna come with you it's gonna come
across as you're saying they're gonna
smell your recruitment breath forever
and um they're not gonna it's not gonna
it's not it's not authentic you have to
be authentic about you have to actually
do it like a lot of companies working
this way a lot of companies don't
because it doesn't suit what they want
how they want to go about it so don't do
something just because you think it's
that's i've heard they do that so that's
a good idea it's got to be
what you actually believe in
so what what's been um what's been some
of the key differences you think that
you've picked up on so far on like doing
the uk europe markets that you've done
in the past to you know
any differences
it's like
it's
fairly similar okay um obviously there's
a lot more uh
it's a lot bigger place and there's a
lot more work
um the margins are slightly bigger
because the salaries are bigger yeah it
sounds bigger margin because so the fees
are bigger but you've got to treat it
like
it's lots of different countries i think
that you've got the focus
yeah yeah they're staying
focused on the state because otherwise
you could get lost in it so yeah
it's helped me be a lot more focused on
what we're going after um
they're a lot more receptive
to
picking up the phones so speaking
because i think um yeah well there's
like forty thousand recruitment agencies
in england and i think there's half of
that in america than this like three
times
yeah so
not more receptive and uh
yeah it's i think you're seen much more
as a
a profession yeah as a profession and
unnecessary something that we need to
help us yes
as a plug-in to their businesses rather
than oh excuses ringing me again
how how have you how so how have you
because i asked you about this when we
were just chatting and stuff like how
have you found hiring for your business
because obviously these people work in
american hours right yeah that's no joke
for some people yeah but how have you
yeah how one have you found it and then
two i know we spoke about that how have
you
made sure like it's really clear what
the sort of characters or what the goal
is yeah let's tell us a bit about that
yeah so everyone that's joined is
obviously working austin hours so we do
2 p.m until midnight
2 pm until midnight yeah in the office
four days a week and then fridays you're
at home okay um
you don't work fridays if you do
american house because yeah it's
difficult yeah yeah we all do that in
office but as i say it's four and it's a
means to an end because we are opening
an office there so there's a goal right
that's the goal everyone's going
everyone's going and i like that's a
promise that's that's happening if you
work in the usa team with us and we hit
this goal as a team then we're all going
um and i think that's really important
because a lot of time
and it's showing good results everyone's
helping each other because they're all
in we're all in it together yeah it's
not like i would unjest like you're like
jess and jack are competing against each
other you are slightly but it's all a
good rule in the journey together um and
it's
it's much more of a
we've got a highly motivated team
because of that um so the strategy here
then just to i guess build some really
good momentum from the uk yeah so then
when you get over to austin like you've
got a really good solid landing that you
can then build on so the plan with the
america would be us
five now yeah
yeah five yeah should know that
um there's five yeah because we've got
harry style on monday but yeah we've got
um five of us
um
we'll be the the core team yeah all
working together learning a bit about it
because it's very difficult you couldn't
just go right call we're gonna go and
start opening office out there yeah yeah
and then pick out so you've got like
sort of learning ways of working make
sure that we can actually do it
get uh get that core team pick them up
go over to austin and then from there
we'll hire
from america like within local locally
and then build the team from there but
we've got the core from from us that
that we've been working in the uk office
so that's that's the plan hopefully
um and yet when you're hoping to have
that we'll be there this time next year
really yeah like yeah there's not that
much family over there so this is the
what are you currently trying to we're
working out no no no no so um
we'll we're gonna go obviously we've got
uh we've got a young 18 month roll
didn't it so we're going to go to the
planet me my partner and the baby will
come out and out there for a year at
least and see how we get on yeah yeah um
and if we love it we'll stay if not
we'll come back and then we'll open up
another and i'll get a different job i'd
like to have a different office how have
you found like the whole visa situation
and stuff because i know we've started
to go through that process is it
difficult sometimes people may think or
has it been pretty straightforward so
far or we've we haven't had any issues
we've got a really good lawyer to help
us with that um obviously it's taking
slightly more time because of you know
everything that's been going on um
but yeah as long as you ain't uh
not done anything dodgy
you should be all right yeah yeah um but
yeah we haven't had any issues with it
yet touchwood but yeah we're starting
that process i'm sure some stuff will
come up
uh further down the line
so what what's as we come to the end
then what what's top of mind this year
then like what what are the main things
that you and your business partner
really focusing on making sure that you
and the team are really keeping a close
eye on and making sure you're performing
in the key areas like what's going to be
really key to you guys
to get to america or i suppose we're not
just all about america obviously you've
got the european union so yeah it's not
just this as a business
so it's
to con to
continue
being
selling these solutions and being known
as a a solution provider rather than a
recruitment business um
so it's setting ourselves in that
position rather than yeah the
transaction side that's that's really
important to us um we want to double the
business
in terms of everything profit revenue
head count we just want to get we want
to do that obviously getting out to
america
we've started obviously traditionally uk
based our uk
clients we've now started doing a lot of
work in europe but matt's just done an
amazing job with that he's been running
that
any particular part of europe uh germany
mainly um
and
continue to build that out
um
for me i just want everyone in our
business to progress and move up move up
from where they are now to move up a
level and start building teams so that's
really important to me um
so there's a number of different things
really um
being positioned as i say as the
solution provider but making sure that
the business grows and with that people
grow within it um that's that's a real
real real thing passion of passion for
me is to develop the people
come a long way since uh
not doing a doing yeah first eight
months yeah you don't what companies
different countries it's mad it's not so
it's really strange like to see like in
just three years
been working obviously in recruitment
for 10 11 years i think it'd be 11 years
in july this year yeah but um
the journey we're talking about the
person i was at the beginning to i am
now
in the three years that i've been doing
cold tech
what do you feel like you've grown up
yeah like just i'm a different person
from when i started the business
um in a good way in a much yeah
hopefully
now i've become a [ __ ] person
everyone hates me that no um
yeah i've grown up obviously
since we started coldtech i've had a
baby he's now 18 months old um
renovated the house um so we've changed
that and i've done a lot of work on that
obviously getting married um it's all
been going on there yeah we've had it
i've been busy so i had like really
healthy ginger beers
it's been uh fantastic it's the best
thing i've ever done um and i'm just
really really happy that uh the
recruitment sector has enabled me to
to be able to do this um yeah and yeah
it's just i'm just really
really proud of myself absolutely well
look
final question for me is just like pete
the people that listen to this want to
perform better want to improve want to
achieve their goals so i guess just
final thing that maybe you want to share
with people is to like if they want to
absolutely smash their goals this year
like as a recruiter or high performing
recruit what what would you say to them
that you think would really what should
they be thinking about what should they
be doing day in day out that can really
give them that chance of achieving their
goals i think the most like really
really really important thing in that
it's like people say i've got this i
want to achieve this i want to do that
right now how you're going to do that
i want to get to experience i want to do
this i want to have a house whatever
call what do you need to do that so work
backwards yeah from the goal
break it down into manageable parts so
that means every day you need to do this
yeah and have that there well i need to
and then just don't have non-negotiables
yourself i need to do that
or yeah i'm not leaving or and set
yourself
to break it down into two hour chunks so
every day
you're hitting
two hour sprints that's how we work in
the business two aspects right you will
need to do that what's the inputs you
need to do so you know exactly what
you've got to do yeah and then it's a
competition with yourself
um so have so in ways that you're going
to hit your goals
sorry all right hit your goals and smash
them as you say like go through those
things is to know what they are and know
how you're going to get there and then
break it down and then make sure you
show up every day and knowing what you
need to do just yeah don't just turn up
and be like i'm here today all right
bomb sit down make your cup of tea you
know before you go in the night before
um
know what you're gonna do the next day
and then come in and make sure you do it
and then you know that's that's it if
you do that every day
you will improve but it's all about like
they said they're like uk cycling like
one percent gain every day
yeah marginal gains that you ain't got
to make huge changes in your life just
do something every day show up and make
sure you have a non-negotiable of
yourself that you're going to do that
and then if you promise yourself you're
going to do it because i could sit there
and go kind of shame what you're going
to do yeah i'm just going to get free
cvs out or whatever i'm going to speak
to 10 clients today oh mate
but
there's no consequence to me that all
i'm going to do is shout at you or
whatever you know
if you punish yourself that then you
feel like a bit disappointed
yeah when you look at yourself in the
mirror you've got to be like i didn't do
what i said i'm going to do and have
that accountability to yourself if you
do that you will achieve what you need
to do well pat it's been a pleasure
thanks coming on the pod i'm i'm excited
to see where cole take our tea see you
in austin yeah yeah i love that out of a
pure gray beard uh by my
company's fourth birthday um but yeah
i've been really genuinely really
appreciate uh
having having me on here i think we
spoke about me coming on when i first
started the business like years and
years ago um so um yeah i'm finally yeah
i'm glad to find a beer in the dream
factory
uh yeah thank you very much for having
me love it really appreciate it
thank you so much for listening to the
episode i hope you enjoyed it and got
value from the conversation if you did
enjoy it please don't forget to like
share and subscribe and we'll see you in
the next episode